[Music]
hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm and today we're talking
about genetics and how much they impact
muscle growth how much they impact
hypertrophy for for the more astute
viewer before we move on just know that
when I talk about genetics it's not
necessarily the the more classical
definition of genetics just purely the
coding portions of a's t c's and g's i'm
using genetics kind of as a shorthand
for the innate factors you're dealing
with that influence your results so
those are the genes themselves but it
also includes things like copy number
variations so how many copies of each
gene you have gene expression so at the
genetic factors which is another big
umbrella factors in utero and childhood
that impact gene expression and then
also phenotypic factors prior to you
know actually starting training so when
i talk about genetics just know that
that's kind of a shorthand for all of
those and made factors that are you know
more or less set but still somewhat
plastic when you first pick up of
barbells so with that out of the way
there are two studies i want to look at
one is by baman and colleagues and the
other is by davidson they'll both be
linked in the description and just know
that this is just kind of a snippet of a
longer article about genetics and just
training and performance in general that
i'm working on
but yeah so so the first one by Bayman
what they did is they recruited 66
untrained people put them on a pretty
solid training program actually looking
at quad growth so it was three times a
week
squat leg press and leg extensions for
three sets of eight to twelve every day
so nine sets per workout
seven sets per week all sets taken to
volitional failure so you know pretty
solid training program if you're looking
to looking to see differences in quad
growth so it was 66 people and then they
used a statistical technique called
k-means clustering to divide them into
three different groups one group they
termed non-responders moderate
responders and extreme responders so
first first things first before we move
on I kind of I want to address those
terms because they're somewhat
misleading so the non-responders group
they on average did not they're her
quads didn't get any bigger over the
course of the study but to call them
non-responders is probably not entirely
accurate all that says is that they
didn't respond to the training program
that was run in the study that doesn't
that doesn't mean that they that there's
no way that their muscles could be
bigger just that they didn't respond to
that particular training program and
then the extreme responders with with
that type of wording people people kind
of get the idea that they are just like
extreme outliers but keep in mind that
there were 66 people in the study and
the top 17 people were termed extreme
responders so you know this isn't one in
a million
type of people these are you know
roughly 1/6 of the participants involved
and the participants weren't all say
like young college-age men like are in
most studies it was split evenly between
20 to 35 year old men 20 to 35 year old
women 60 to 75 year old I believe men
and 60 to 75 year old women and it's
also worth pointing out that each each
age and sex each age and sex cluster was
represented in all three responder types
so the the majority of the extreme
responders were young
as you'd expect but there were also I
think one or two elderly women in that
cluster and there were also young men in
the non-responder cluster so all all for
age and sex groupings were represented
in all three clusters anyway so with
that out of the way
the results were we're pretty
eye-popping so like I said about the
lowest sixth of the responders on
average did not gain any muscle size
whatsoever some of them got a tiny
little bit bigger some of them actually
their muscles cut slightly smaller so 16
weeks training hard and your muscles get
smaller so that sucks the moderate
responder group so roughly the middle
2/3 of participants on average their
quads got increased in cross-sectional
area by about 28% if memory serves and
the extreme responders so again not one
in a million type people but the top
sixth the top six of people in terms of
muscle growth their quads on average got
58% larger so slightly more than twice
the growth of the modest responders and
then I'll flash results up here as well
there's one guy I'm assuming it's a guy
who is almost an outlier among the
extreme responders as well so you'll see
most of them kind of cluster towards
sort of the modest responders and then
there's one dude who just got even way
more jacked than everyone else did so if
if his starting muscle cross-sectional
area was anywhere close to the group
means that means his quads had increased
in cross-sectional area by about 70% so
huge huge difference in response right
there
and then you see similar things in
Davidson's study as well so I don't
remember the exact details of that
training program but I I remember it was
also solid it was a study out of
McMaster University if memory serves and
they know how to run a good training
study yeah and so it was basically the
same thing it was 12 weeks of training
looking at changes in lean body mass and
again there was a huge difference
between low responders and high
responders they split them into two
groups for analysis roughly three to
four fold difference
um with the top top people in the high
responders group a couple people gained
six kilos of lean mass in 12 weeks and
these were untrained people
recreationally active but not lifters
but you know that's first three months
under the bar gaining like thirteen
thirteen and a half pounds of muscle
that's ridiculous
and the group average for the high
responders was about four kilos of
muscles so closer to nine pounds of
muscle in 12 weeks so you know not too
far off of a pound of a pound a week
whereas the low responders yeah should
have got the exact number but it was it
was closer to about a kilo and a half of
muscle so you know there's not too much
you can do with this information it's
just something that it's it's good to be
aware of and something else to point out
about both of these studies is that
there weren't any significant
differences between high responders and
low responders or extreme moderate and
non responders at the start of the study
going into it on average their muscles
were basically the same size they're
like you you wouldn't be able to tell
the high responders from the low
responders just by looking at them I
wasn't until they actually got under the
bar that you know big differences in
hypertrophy actually you know manifested
themselves so um you know that's that's
just a good thing to be aware of this
this kind of relates to my to my last
video about the law of truly large
numbers by the way I said it's going to
start uploading like three times a week
and I think that video is from July or
August so yeah really dropped the ball
there but I'm gonna try to pick it back
up not making any promises though but
but yeah so in both of these studies you
had basically a bell curve in responses
which is what you would expect know
because you're dealing with you know
biological creatures we tend to exist on
bell curves and you know it's it's worth
pointing out one of these studies had I
think 56 people maybe 54 56 something
like that and one of them 66 people and
you still got that big of a range and
responses so you know people in both
studies lost small amounts of muscle
over the course of the study and people
in both
studies gained tons of quad thickness
you know 13 pounds of lean body mass
over the course of 12 weeks like huge
gains and so thing to keep in mind is
when you're dealing with bell curves
the odds that you're dealing with
someone who's truly a freak in sample
sizes of 50 60 people it's pretty small
so you know those those when you're so
let's say you're dealing with a sport
like powerlifting bodybuilding several
thousand competitors and both sports
odds are extremely extremely good that
the people who do the best in those two
sports are probably substantially more
genetically endowed than the top people
even in those studies who you know got
results in 12 16 weeks that were truly
eye-popping so and then also some people
really do just have a tough run of just
have a tough run of luck in terms of the
hand that they were dealt so you know
just because someone isn't super big
super strong that doesn't mean that they
aren't necessarily putting in the work
and you know getting getting everything
out of it that they could be some people
just weren't dealt a great hand and then
on the other hand you know some people
it just seems like they can look at a
weight and get bigger and stronger and
and those people are out there and
they're not they're not is one of the
main points I want to make is those
people aren't as rare as we like to
think so the people who do have you know
a really poor hand they're plain those
were about was 6 - the people in those 2
studies so you may you may not see those
people that often at gyms because you
know likely if they started training and
they don't get any bigger you know they
don't mean any muscle or very very
little they probably don't stick with it
but you know those people aren't all
that uncommon and the people who get
really really crazy good results you
know it's not every person walking down
the street but it's not
it's not nearly as uncommon as as people
think it is so oh yeah and then the the
key point I wanted to make here again
going back to the fact that pre-training
there weren't big differences between
high responders and low responders one
of the things I always come back to in a
lot of theoretically one of these days
in a lot of videos but in a lot of
articles definitely is you don't know
how good of a hand you were dealt let's
say you actually play it you know you
shouldn't you shouldn't start with
assumptions that limit yourself you
shouldn't start with those self-limiting
beliefs you know if if you're not
expecting much then that does give you
kind of a security blanket so then if
you don't achieve much you know since
you were coming into it with low
expectations
you don't really beat yourself up about
it but at the same time having high
beliefs high expectations about yourself
that is probably going to you know
actually impact your results in a
positive way
pretty notably so I wrote I wrote an
article a few articles about that
looking at some classy bow research on
steroids that I'll link in the
description but so it's been like 13
minutes so that that's enough rambling
for now but again genetics just there's
there's a much bigger spread than then I
think most people realize and main thing
I wanted to get across in this video is
just how large that spread is and how
relatively common the people on either
end of that continuum are and the fact
that you know you don't know how good or
how bad you're doing that your genetics
are until you actually train hard put in
the work
expect to get results and then you know
you may just surprise yourself you may
wind up disappointed but you know you
don't know until you try so that's about
it thanks for watching and hope it won't
be 5 months until my next step load